sur la majorité des véhicules des
affiches signalant la présence d'enfants
à bord ces familles ukrainienne arrive
tout juste de mario paul chaque jour ils
sont plusieurs centaines de civils à se
rendre à la police via au péril de leur
vie
cet habitant de la région raconte son
quotidien sous les bombardements de
l'armée russe
on a vécu sous l'occupation pendant deux
mois on a souffert constamment sont
attendus qu'on vienne le chercher mais
personne n'est arrivé en deux mois alors
on a décidé de partir quelqu'un nous a
aidés mais il n'y avait pas de couloirs
humanitaires
rien de tout ça
la ville portuaire de marioupol est
aujourd'hui presque entièrement détruite
les tentatives d'évacuation quasiment
toutes échoué environ cent mille
habitants seraient toujours sur place
selon des estimations des autorités
ukrainiennes
on attend des gens de marioupol tous les
jours mais le dernier convoi avec quatre
buts date de la semaine dernière c'est
le seul convoi arrivait par un film en
humanitaire pour ce qui est de la
promesse de l'onu et bien oui aux
attentes on n'a aucune idée
on attend
une attente interminable
alors que les nations unies ont annoncé
ce jeudi se rendent sur place pour
préparer une évacuation la ville martyre
est presque entièrement contrôlé par les
russes à l'exception de ce gigantesque
complexe métallurgique
l'aciérie d'azov stahl deux à trois
mille soldats ukrainien ils sont
toujours retranchés assiégée par les
forces russes qui bombardent sans
relâche la zone dans les sous sols de
lusine il y aussi des centaines de
civils dont des enfants et la nourriture
l'eau les médicaments se font de plus en
plus rares
les derniers combattants ont jusqu'ici
refusé de se rendre mais ils multiplient
les appels pour être exfiltré